deedy King Kabbalah from the NFL Network
joining me right here on the Rich Eisen
show cuz she knows this locker room very
well how did that whole thing hit you
yesterday DD just absurd at this point
rich I mean it audio brown got every
single thing that he wanted he got out
of town he got a new contract he got
more guaranteed money and he went to the
team and the coach that he actually
wanted to play for so why is juju Smith
Shuster still getting under his skin why
is he wasting his time getting in these
fights and as you're saying these little
social media stats if we don't want to
call them fights and as you're saying
he's lost a complete amount of respect I
mean we've seen Eric Weddle we've seen
Justin Reed we've seen all these players
around the league right now go back to
social media and say wow don't have a
lot of respect for this guy anymore or
as Justin Reed said can't wait to hit
this guy how did it land and land in the
Steelers locker room over the last 24
hours best you can tell I think that
there are quite a few players right now
that are sitting here and saying okay
there's some vindication in the sense
that maybe more as one player texted me
this morning he said maybe now more of
the national media will realize it's not
the Steelers that are a complete
dysfunctional mess but that there were
certain triggers or certain where does
where is the blame supposedly where
should the blame be centered I guess is
the way that you phrased it I'm trying
to be very careful in how I rephrase
sure I understand because again it's
just it's amazing that we're relitigated
this and I guess we'll do this for a
little bit now and should something
happen between now and the beginning of
the season certainly if as I I think it
would happen that the Steelers wind up
in New England for the first Sunday
night game of the year to see what they
look like post brown post bail but just
really just walk me through again what
the hell did happen in week 17 and and
whose fingerprints are all over it and
how much juju Smith's used to or
jealousy in his direction played into
all of that this is this is and I talked
to you about this earlier rich this is
like
bernd lover or this is like a
relationship god bad benin a b ben
roethlisberger and antonio brown had
this phenomenal wonderful amazing
relationship for five years the two of
them were tightest can be a year ago ben
roethlisberger said of all the great
receivers he'd ever had tonio home
behind or to mike wallace and Plex ago
Burris the greatest chemistry he has
ever had it with Antonio Brown now early
this year going all the way back to OTAs
Antonio Brown Ben Roethlisberger not
necessarily on the same page a little
bit of a difference in when you show up
to work and how you show up to work the
summer comes it's a little bit odd
Antonio Brown disappears from training
camp for a little while there's
definitely some ego at play the season
starts the two of them just don't seem
to be connecting really well and what
had been so magical for them which even
Brown's new coach Jon Gruden had talked
about or sort of the improvised plays
the way that the two of them could make
things up together they weren't really
working so well anymore and Ben
Roethlisberger meanwhile was
unbelievably to use the same metaphor
here flirtatious with juju Smith
Schuster he was so pleased with the way
that juju would run his routes exactly
as expected show up exactly where he
needed to show up was not really making
waves and was never sitting here calling
for the ball in any way or having a
meltdown on the sidelines or taking
offense at anything so the more Ben
Roethlisberger talked up juju Smith
Shuster the more that ate a little bit
into Ed Antonio Brown now fast forward
Antonio Brown engineers a break up
Antonio Brown and Ben Roethlisberger
have broken up but a Antonio Brown is
still pissed off apparently at the
girlfriend who has followed him which is
Judy Smith Schuster and I probably
shouldn't be using these feminine or
masculine whatever but I mean that's
what it completely strike almost
everyone here as I talked to a player
yesterday who said the same exact thing
that it's basically like a bad breakup
and you can't handle who your
replacement is I talked to somebody who
today who said this just justifies why
Antonio Brown won the
dynamic players in the NFL ultimately
have to be sent out of this locker room
and so again the Steelers are sitting
here and they've essentially said since
the end of the season that this may end
up being addition by subtraction and
Antonio Brown sure isn't doing anything
to lay lie to that idea right now
a Dede thanks for calling in and give us
your two cents in between
up-to-the-minute hits on the NFL Network
I appreciate it well I appreciate it I
need hi red you got it we'll chat again
soon I'm sure that's a DD Kent caballo
who covers the Steelers and so many
other teams for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app